One of the most important aspects
of teaching the humanities...
is to transmit cultural values across time.
We pursue the study with the conviction
that we’re training global citizens.
Expanding your horizons
and learning how to ask new questions...
and learning how to have
your questions answered.
This is a place that has art museums
that are unique...
in their depth and their breadth.
The humanities shift and change
as the great public issues...
and public questions of our times change.
By the time you graduate and you’ve picked
a concentration or a major...
you’re really poised to do many
and often unpredictable things.
Harvard is, in the best sense,
a global university.